China reported a hundred and eight new
coronavirus cases yesterday its highest
number in almost six weeks that's bad
news for the country where the outbreak
began and where most travel restrictions
ended just last week as Raymond Ascencio
reports from Tokyo health officials in
other countries warned that the virus is
returning this new pop-up hospital in
sway fonta in northeast China is the
country's latest battleground against
coronavirus with 600 beds state media
showed workers setting up rooms for
infected patients Chinese officials say
most of the country's new infections are
imported this town of 80,000 right on
the border with Russia is now on
lockdown less than a week ago
Wuhan celebrated its liberation from a
76 day lockdown but that joy came with a
warning from some still there like
professor Sarah plateau the virus will
not disappear in uptick in infection
numbers is now being reported across
Asia and now a new worry viral
reactivation more than 100 people who
recovered in South Korea have tested
positive again in terms of a second
surge are you nervous right now I am
nervous dr. Jerome Kim is an
epidemiologist based in Seoul what I
hope is that what we see instead are
little blips so it's like putting out a
fire you know that they're gonna be
embers that are glowing or smoking you
want to stamp those out before the fire
starts again and here in Japan a fire
has started again the northern island of
Hokkaido has Reda clared a state of
emergency because of a resurgence of
infections there Japan now has more than
7500 reported infections that's three
times as many as April first for CBS
this morning
ramie innocencio Tokyo